[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el vaticano
decidió esta semana reformar las leyes
de la iglesia católica una de las
revisiones más radicales en décadas para
castigar a los clérigos que cometan
delitos de pedofilia para hablar de este
tema nos acompaña el doctor james
hamilton víctima de abuso cuando estaba
joven por parte del cura chileno
fernando karadima gracias doctor
hamilton por estar con nosotros y
compartir su historia porque esta
reforma del derecho canónico era una de
las peticiones de muchas de las víctimas
bueno muy buenos días a todos encantado
de estar acá
es
es un anhelo gigantesco para las
personas que todavía tienen 13 l y este
católicos participan de este creo que
esta evolución acorde a la realidad y
aún hace realmente evangélicas en cristo
donde éste reconoce nuestros crímenes
donde se reparan los crímenes y era
necesario y fundamental que es la menos
tiene el código de derecho canónico
estuviera establecido y tipificado el
delito de pedofilia no sólo eso sino que
también todos los delitos relacionados
el doming y el tratar de llevar a
jóvenes a la pornografía etcétera todo
esto en un contexto donde se reconoce
que esto ocurre en un contexto donde
también se haga la reparación a víctimas
y esto es un enorme avance gigantesco
porque además de alguna manera es el
inicio del camino hacia la justicia
sobre todo hacia la prevención de estos
delitos pasaron muchos años para que se
abrirá una investigación formal sobre
los abusos de los clérigos y su modesto
el silencio de la iglesia católica ahora
el papá francisco ha tenido un papel
determinante en el 2018 despojo de su
condición de sacerdote karadima y ahora
viene esta reforma al derecho canónico
como evalúa usted el actuar del vaticano
en esta reforma
bueno creo que la reforma es importante
porque también apunta al hecho de que
aquellos obispos o
víctor es de órdenes religiosas en la
medida que encubra o sea poco prolijos
por omisión no se preocupen de hacer
justicia y deben anunciar también van a
ser sancionados esto de alguna manera
empieza
cerrar un capítulo que viene ya hace
muchos años también nos sentimos
nosotros con mis compañeros juan carlos
cruz y josé murillo en nuestro compraros
masilla hoy contento porque pensamos que
algún grano de arena contribuyó la
visita que estuvimos hace ya más de dos
años el vaticano donde nos recibió el 5
y donde hablamos de justamente estos
temas donde este arroyo del cubrimiento
donde se habló la necesidad de cambiar
él
derecho canónico que fue además
una piedra contra la cual nosotros
tocamos múltiples veces y donde se
jugarán vivos en chile- obispos que
fueron claramente mos la justicia y
ordenados por no sólo obstrucción a la
justicia sino que complicidad
james para terminar que falta que más
falta para reparar a las víctimas
sí sí
es importante ahora que esta medida que
está tomando el papá francisco se lleve
a todas las diócesis y diócesis del
mundo es muy necesario ella
está como esta indicación de la cabeza
de la iglesia vaya terminado
toda la iglesia de la tónica me sale y
quien los obispos lo que llaman los
ordinarios de cada lugar la asuman y
hagan su labor como corresponde yo creo
que todavía queda tiempo para que muchos
obispos que siguen siendo encubridores y
muchos de ellos abusadores sean de
alguna manera
eliminado o habían desplazado a sus
funciones en el tee que se vaya
renovando la intención con unas personas
con un 'toque' acción real humilde
semana evangélica y moderna que también
haga eco de lo que es la obesidad y las
necesidades reales de la gente en
particular de los fieles quienes han
visto muchísimas gracias de nuevo por
compartir esta historia con nosotros a
ustedes gracias quédense porque más
mucho más en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]